We create quite a bit of documentation
in the world of IT and whenever there's
an incident, we always need to create an
incident report. Incident reports
commonly provide information on what led
up to the incident, the incident itself,
and then how the organization reacted to
the actual problem. These reports
provide us with documentation that we
can use to describe the incident itself
and then what we did prior to and after
the incident occurring. Most
organizations will have a formal
incident response plan and this plan
commonly describes exactly what process
the organization should take whenever an
incident occurs. This creates an ongoing
database of these incidents so that we
can understand exactly what led up to
the incident, the incident itself and
then how the organization reacted once
the incident was identified. This gives
us a way to analyze what has occurred in
the past so that we can apply that
towards preventing these situations from
occurring in the future.
Every organization has a different way
of working. There are usually a set of
processes and procedures to follow
depending on what needs to be done. Most
organizations will document all of these
processes and procedures into a single
set of standard operating procedures.
This way, there's documentation that can
guide us for whatever situation we might
find ourselves in. For example, if
there's downtime, we need to know what
the process is for handling that
downtime situation. Who do we contact
first to be able to address the downtime
itself? And then who do we contact to
inform them that the downtime has
occurred? Or perhaps we're having a
facilities problem. Perhaps we've lost
power at a remote site. We need to
understand who to contact internally and
we need to understand who we should
contact at the power company to inform
them of this outage. These standard
procedures also impact our day-to-day
processes. For example, we might need to
install a software package and there
might be a custom installation process
that is documented in the standard
operating procedures or we might have
broad procedures applied towards things
like testing an application or providing
a change control process. The key is to
have all of this documentation already
predefined and available for whoever
needs access. This means if you're
working on a help desk, you know exactly
the process to be able to handle a
particular problem. And if you're
working at a remote site, you know all
of the processes and procedures
associated with that site.
Most organizations will also have
documentation regarding the onboarding
of new employees. If somebody's new to
the organization, there are a number of
processes that need to take place
internally so that that person is able
to start working immediately on day one.
This documentation might include IT
agreements that need to be signed by the
employee who's starting. This might be a
very broad document where the incoming
employee agrees to everything that's in
the employee handbook or it might be a
very specific acceptable use policy or
AUP that we want to have the user sign
separately. These onboarding tasks will
also include the process of creating a
new account or series of accounts for
this user. This also includes
information about the rights and
permissions required for this user. So
we can make sure that this person's
accounts are associated with the
appropriate groups and the appropriate
departments. And there may be equipment
that needs to be acquired for this new
user. We need to make sure that the new
employee has a laptop, a tablet, a
desktop computer, or any other
technology that they need to accomplish
their job.
Just as we have a set of processes and
procedures for bringing people into the
organization, we also have a set of very
standardized procedures when people are
offboarding. This should obviously be a
set of processes that have been defined
well before someone leaves the
organization because we need to know
exactly what to do the moment someone is
no longer an employee of the company.
For example, what are the procedures for
the hardware that is used by this
person? They probably have a laptop, a
mobile device, maybe they have a desktop
computer, and we need a set of processes
and procedures on how those assets are
to be managed. Perhaps even more
importantly, we need to understand what
to do with the data that this person was
responsible for. Is this information
backed up? Has it been handed off to a
different person? Is there anything
encrypted that we need to be sure we
have decryption keys for? And anything
else associated with that data needs to
be documented in the offboarding
processes and procedures. This prevents
us from accidentally deleting
information that may be important for
later.
Another important document used by an
organization is an SLA. This is a
service level agreement. This is usually
a document that is created in
conjunction with a service provider. For
example, there might be a set of minimum
terms that are associated with your
internet service provider. A service
level agreement with an ISP might
require a certain uptime or response
time associated with that service. These
SLAs's are commonly put into the
contract you have with a thirdparty
service provider, but you could also use
SLAs's internally within your
organization to specify what the minimum
requirements might be when working with
the IT department or a different
department in the organization. Here's
an example of the SLA terms you might
add to a contract with your internet
service provider. You might have an SLA
that says you may have no more than 4
hours of unscheduled downtime in an
entire year. And if there's more than
four hours of downtime during that year,
there might be a credit or some type of
penalty associated with that SLA. The
SLA might also say that a technician
will be dispatched if there is a long
period of downtime. And there might be a
requirement as part of that contract
that the customer keep spare equipment
on site. So if there is a downtime, they
can send a technician and that
technician can use that equipment to get
everything back up and running as
quickly as possible.
From a technical perspective, some of
the most valuable documentation you can
have is a knowledge base. This commonly
provides detailed technical information
on how to support hardware, software, or
some other type of technology. This
might be a knowledge base that is
provided and supported by an external
vendor. For example, Microsoft has an
extensive knowledge base that provides
you with detailed information about the
inner workings of the Windows operating
system. Or you might be able to find
detailed technical information on a
third-party internet website. There's
also a great deal of information that is
institutional within your own company.
There are specialized applications and
different ways of doing things that
would be useful to document as part of a
knowledge base. Very often, this is a
feature built into help desk software
that you may already be using. So, it
may be as easy as turning on that
feature or adding additional articles to
your help desk software. Knowledge bases
provide us with a way to find detailed
information in a sea of data. This is
usually a searchable archive. And if
you're integrating with your help desk
software, you might see knowledgebased
articles appear as part of the help desk
ticket itself. This means that things
that we may have put into the knowledge
base a year ago might appear in a new
help desk ticket to help with the
resolution process.